[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les 38 000 communes de France 27
millions d'électeurs ont choisi entre le
Wii que demander le général de Gaulle et
le nom que soutenait ses opposants que
ce soit dans les villages de province ou
les quartiers de la capitale française
et français ont eu à trancher au fond de
leur conscience le débat ouvert entre
les parties et le chef de l'État sur
l'élection au suffrage universel du
président de la République ce débat sa
sortie c'est à la vérité du souvenir des
erreurs passées de la crainte de
lendemain difficile il s'assortissait
également d'une passion que jusqu'ici
aucun autre référendum n'avait suscité
c'est dans cette ambiance un peu lourde
que les Français ont voté
à la mairie de Colombelles et deux
églises redevenues pour un moment simple
citoyen le général de Gaulle a comme
tout le monde déposé son bulletin
[Musique]
dès le soir aux Champs-Élysées les
Parisiens suivaient l'apparition
successive des résultats
un soiré au ministère de l'Intérieur
monsieur Roger frais faisait devant les
journalistes l'analyse du scrutin
62,10% des suffrages pour le oui
37,90% pour le nom voici donc le général
de Gaulle confirmé au pouvoir à une
heure ou une crise ne pouvait avoir que
de fatals conséquences
[Musique]
l'amitié de la Finlande pour la France a
toujours été sincère et profonde a dit
Monsieur hour ok connaît au général de
Gaulle venus accueillir à Orly c'est
dans la chaleur de cette amitié que
devait se dérouler pendant trois jours
la première visite d'un président de la
République finlandaise à Paris visite
dont la partie officielle se termine par
le gala donné à l'Opéra et qui a réuni
autour de Monsieur kekanen et du général
de Gaulle les plus hautes personnalités
de l'État
au cours de l'histoire récente la France
et la Finlande ont eu l'occasion de
s'apprécier elles viennent à travers ce
voyage de souligner avec éclat qu'elles
entendent poursuivre cette amitié
[Musique]
le prix Nobel de littérature a été
décerné à John Steinbeck dont chacun se
rappelle certains titres des souris et
des hommes les vers pâturage et les
raisins de la colère entre autres c'est
la sixième fois que cette distinction
récompense en américain les derniers
furent folkner et Hemingway
dans un genre tout différent le prix des
Palmes d'or attribué annuellement à
Paris à un roman d'espionnage est allé à
Maurice Gabriel Braun pour sa dernière
œuvre apôtre de la violence Catherine
Langeais Mick Michel Félix Martens
ouvrage on ose plus dire qu'il promet
[Musique]
davantage encore d'étudiants à Paris
c'est-à-dire des problèmes accrus et
l'année a commencé par des
manifestations devant le vénérable
institut mille étudiants en médecine ont
réclamé des centres hospitaliers
à la gare Saint-Lazare 200 autres
étudiants ont envahi la salle des pas
perdue pour s'y installer avec duvet et
couverture et attirer ainsi l'attention
sur le manque de logement
il fallut qu'elle énergies aux agents de
police pour résorber cet encombrement
supplémentaire à une heure de pointe
[Musique]
le monde avec une semaine dramatique en
mission de surveillance au-dessus de
Cuba les avions U2 américains
photographiés à la construction et
l'établissement de rampe de lancement de
fusée dont l'existence ne pouvait plus
passer pour une mesure défensive
or Cuba n'est en cas 200 km les côtes
américaines jusqu'à New York étaient
tenus sous le feu des fusées à courte
portée tandis que les engins à moyenne
portés menacaient les deux tiers des
territoires des États-Unis
c'est photographié allaient déclencher
l'alerte dans un discours imprévu le
président Kennedy dénonçait le péril ces
bases disaient-ils ne peuvent avoir
d'autres raisons que de fournir une
force de frappe nucléaire dirigée contre
nous
il lançait en même temps le poids de la
flotte américaine dans la balance en
décritant le blocus pour toute
équipement militaire offensive à
destination de Cuba or à ce même moment
25 Argos Soviétiques étaient déjà en
route qu'alait-il sortir de la rencontre
les cargo accepteraient-ils le contrôle
tenterait-il de forcer le passage les
heures commençaient à se faire lourdes
sur la côte américaine les radars
étaient déjà en état d'alerte on suivait
dans les caves des états majors la
marche des cargo dont certains
disaient-on étaient porteurs de fusées à
charge nucléaire or les consignes
étaient strictes si les cargo tentaient
de se soustraire au contrôle et
prétendait continuer leur chemin l'ordre
était de tirer
c'est dans cette atmosphère que le
Conseil de sécurité se réunit d'urgence
plein de l'URSS accusant les États-Unis
de piraterie par la bouche de Monsieur
zorine
plainte de Cuba
plainte des États-Unis par la voie de
Monsieur Stevenson
dans le même temps à l'Organisation des
États d'Amérique réunis en séance
extraordinaire la place de Cuba était
demeurée vide et celle des États-Unis
était occupé par le ministre des
Affaires étrangères monsieur Dean rosk
l'assemblée a prouvé les mesures
décidées pour faire face aux dangers
d'agression venant de Cuba
[Musique]
la fièvre était montée au paroxysme les
manifestations de masse pour conspuer
les États-Unis se succèdent
fidèle Castro lui-même va arranguer une
population fanatisée qui brandissait des
pancartes au slogan définitif
la mobilisation générale était déjà
entrée en cours on creusait des
tranchées sur les côtes les postes de
DCA gettaient dans le ciel vide
l'approche des bombardiers US et l'homme
de la rue reprenait l'uniforme
[Applaudissements]
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique diverses
manifestations prenaient pour cible les
ambassades ou les organismes américains
l'une d'entre elles celle d'Alger
répondait à la toute jeune amitié
Algérie Cuba affiché depuis la visite de
Ben Bella à fidèle Castro
[Musique]
quels sortir de cette fièvre dangereuse
aguantanamo la base louée aux Américains
par Cuba pour 99 ans plusieurs milliers
de Marines étaient arrivés en renfort
[Applaudissements]
par contre femme et enfants étaient
évacuées tout était possible et puis le
miracle de la sagesse et de la fermeté
eu raison de la fatalité des dangers en
chaîne ROCHEF détourna ses cargo et
annonce à la destruction des rentes
reste tout de même Guantanamo donc Astro
réclame l'évacuation mais l'heure du
drame est passé
[Musique]
devant l'Allemagne de l'Ouest la
Stuttgart l'équipe de France de football
a confirmé son renouveau et pourtant
sans Raymond copain elle n'avait pas
l'air de grand-chose au début du match
cette équipe de France pendant 25
minutes les solides allemands en maillot
blanc ont donné des sueurs froides aux
supporters français et pourtant c'est la
France qui marque le premier but par
staco
Hitchcock lui-même n'aurait pas mieux
régler le scénario
les Allemands cependant font encore
passer un très mauvais quart d'heure à
l'équipe de France et là on assiste à un
numéro de défense collective de très
grande place
[Applaudissements]
après cette période assez pénible les
avants Français reprennent en main les
opérations on assiste alors à quelques
actions pétillantes à un football plein
de gaieté qui serait irrésistible si les
joueurs français maintenant cette
cadence durant tout le match quoi qu'il
en soit c'est au terme de l'une de ses
actions que la France marque son second
but
[Applaudissements]
deuxième mi-temps les Allemands forcent
la cadence à un moment où les Français
sont peut-être un peu trop décontractés
ou plus simplement un peu fatigué
[Applaudissements]
une nouvelle fois la défense est obligée
de jouer au coude à coup pour éviter le
pire ce qui n'empêche pas les Allemands
de marquer
[Applaudissements]
le but d'égalisation ne va pas tarder
mais ce match nul des Français les
centres voire des succès pour demain
leur première victime sera peut-être la
Hongrie le 11 novembre prochain à Paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]